hey guys this is andrew from
chainsenses.com so i've been working as
a professional trader for the past six
years in hong kong and right now guys
i'm doing
youtube videos because i want to pass
the knowledge i want to
explain to you guys how portrayed is
actually working because i know that you
can find so many different stuff on the
internet and you don't know who you can
trust
so that's why i'm here i really want to
show you guys what is working for me
what is efficient
in my everyday activity and
by doing some updates on different
stocks and show you
how i use my tools so today i want to
talk about tesla let's get into it
[Music]
so i'm doing uh regularly some updates
on tesla so
first let's start on the four hours time
frame so
what we can see is that we were in this
uh descending uh channel
and i was here bullish above 750
and i was thinking that we're gonna go
higher and complete
this final wave that has not been
completed yet
so actually here we broke it on the
downside
fair enough so i was actually thinking
then that this might be the whole
correction and i tried to do my counting
again so i use idiot wave
principle to kind of analyze the
development of the waves and try to see
if the moves is finished or not
and today i spent a lot of time trying
to make this right
so i'm not gonna show you guys how
it was looking actually i can i i
thought it was something like this so
basically
moves up developing five waves this is
the basis of idiot wave principle
and for those who want to know more
about the staff how to use it and the
different patterns and
how you can use those to predict some
very
precise stuff on the market click on the
link in the description of this video
and you're gonna receive a free video
with
theory and practice where i explain
everything about it
so here we have the one two so i thought
it was like this right
i was seeing something like this guys
and then i was like so maybe the fifth
is finished and i was like no the fifth
is not finished the yellow fifths
because it's too short compared to the
one and three so i was like
it's not finished it's not possible so
then i was like oh maybe actually this
is the
the four and that is happening right now
and that the fifth is gonna come later
all right so this is very bullish
to say something like this but like i
said guys
i think this is happening usually idiot
wave counting
you make it correct after the moves
happen what is not easy is to actually
have the right counting before actually
the moves are finished but this is
what is interesting in the theory is
that it's predictive guys so i think
that
one two three so i think that actually
would be four and this makes sense
because as you can see here i did my
counting and each time i can do
five waves and the third wave is the
longest so
this is a proper counting this can
counting is valid and this is actually
making
a lot of sense and this means we are
actually correcting and that the
correction is going to be longer than
expected and that then we're going to
have the fifth wave that
i can give you some targets it's going
to be around 2000 guys but once again
i think we're at the beginning of the
bubble for those who want to know more
about why i think like this what
indicators are used
what are my signals because guys it's
not just the feeling
right it's based on some observations
and based on past data analysis and i
can
tell you guys that i'm very convinced of
this scenario once again i can change my
mind but for now it's my preferred
scenario we're at the beginning of the
bubble and everything is going to take
100 200 percent
everything so some staff are gonna take
one thousand sometimes some stuff is
gonna
is gonna remain flat and tesla is not
from those who
is going to remain flat i can tell you